take a look at this story we got here
from teamcast.com
this is from yesterday kenosha school
district switches to remote learning to
protect students and staff they say
while we have not been advised of any
existing imminent danger we feel this is
the best course of action to protect our
students and staff during an uncertain
time we will continue to work closely
with law enforcement to receive support
as needed in the days and weeks ahead
hundreds of wisconsin national guard
troops are on the ground should any
riding looting or general violence occur
i saw someone on my facebook who's a
pretty far lefty tweet uh tweet not our
story version of it but like just a card
saying kenosha is going remote learning
out of fears of riots and i just
responded with terrorism
and i and and this actually
it worked has there been any reports
well well so the person responded with
something about
how they feel that the left is
terrorizing children and schools and
families
and my point was like i'm not going to
sit here and get into a big long
argument about it but when your schools
are shut down because of left-wing
rioters
terrorism politically motivated so well
it's literally literally terrorism yeah
what the black lives matter protesters
were doing what they were and what
people need to understand is they're
like oh but the people outside the
courthouse are being peaceful it's like
yo
if there's like a mob like a mafia and
the mafia goes and you know they kill
people they do it frequently when the
mafia shows up to your business making
demands those aren't idle threats you
don't say hey well these mafia guys are
being peaceful so they don't mean
anything by it no you're scared you're
like this group is known to be violent
so when you have outside the courthouse
black lives matter so protesters and and
again with respect to them sharing pizza
with everybody i think it's going to
come together but regardless
when you see those protesters and then
you remember what those protesters not
the same people but similar people and
many many of the same people were doing
in kenosha bashing the man over the head
burning down buildings just because
they're being peaceful here doesn't mean
it's not it's not still creating that
sense of fear and and terrorizing people
it feels cyclical so you have riot
shooting trial verdict
riot shooting trial verdict it's like
the human centipede with ar 15. isn't it
isn't that crazy that uh jacob blake
situation resulted in riots which
resulted in kyle rittenhouse being down
there and then this whole precisely and
now they're all encouraged by the state
pushed by the state has there been any
reports coming out of kenosha about
what's happened on the ground and we
know you said it was quite cold that's
one of the things that may kill off the
fair weather riot is but has there been
any reports about that i've not well i
haven't seen anything yet i'm sure
there's something happening we do have
reports coming out of chicago of
protests but granted it's cold
especially in chicago chicago is very
close to kenosha i think it's only like
60 miles or maybe like 70 miles
so fairly close
i mean jessie smallett faced the cold
yeah he's surviving yeah two in the
morning in a in a non-residential
district what if people are weak
now now look i had a viral tweet
recently where i said remember when you
were wrong about russiagate remember
when you were wrong about covington
remember when you were wrong about
kenosha remember when you were wrong
about jesus millet believing the
corporate press is the definition of
insanity now the definition of insanity
is not the colloquial internet version
but the internet version is
sticking your hand doing doing the same
thing over and over again expecting a
different result yeah so that's like you
keep putting your hand in the fire and
going ow this time it'll be different ow
this time will be different this is what
i struggle with though because if you
think about it and we talked about this
last time a little bit how the actual
ratings and numbers for many of these
shows
in the corporate media are so low to the
tune of maybe 100k for some of them
right so this episode of tim cast is
going to get more than most mainstream
news shows talking about this
how do they still have so much influence
how do they still convince people of
this when they're not getting those
numbers for the most part they are
so i can proudly state
that uh cnn and msnbc prime time hln
prime time have nothing on tim cast irl
we get
look so um every night we get several
hundred thousand people who watch live
followed by 700 000 people who watch as
like a standard youtube video rerun
essentially when it's not live
and
eighty percent are the key demo
so we're getting like 400
000 people who are in the key demo and
then when you that's comparable to
tucker carlson now tucker with the older
demographic is getting millions he's
massive
and
cnn cnn and msnbc are getting like 800
000 with you know the older generation
so they're still getting more views than
us
they're still uh so we don't get as many
boomers
boomers still watch msnbc cnn so they
still have influence there but
youtube puts them on the front page if
you search youtube if you go to youtube
on a clean computer you've never opened
before and you type in kyle right now's
verdict you are not getting a tim pool
video you're getting a cnn video where
they're going to give you the falsely
framed narrative and then you'll see it
heavily disliked doesn't it now they're
removing dyslexia
youtube puts the mainstream media on the
front page and so i can sit here and say
we are annihilating them in the key demo
with our live show compared to theirs
you look at youtube and they're getting
a hundred million views per month from
an rv
no no no no cnn no yeah we are we're
annihilating them from it i mean
actually we're cooler though whatever so
that's for sure my channels across the
board all the
my my morning show and and tim castle
combined is like probably 40 or 50
million views
but cnn their main channel gets 100
million per month on youtube
because youtube puts them on the front
they didn't used to like 2000 i started
youtube in 2006 and it they would
feature
tim or me or like you like they were
independent creators not the corporate
media because they were youtube yeah i
was like chris crawford videos and cat
videos yeah but also like if we see
ricata lost stream i mean there's an
over 30k there's an overwhelming amount
of success happening to independent
individuals who are willing to say hey
let's actually take an honest real look
at this and not just have a corporate
trash regurgitated back on to
unsuspecting people who are in a coma
watching the boob tube so i i think also
mike cernovich made a very interesting
point today that i've been trying to get
in uh during the conversations and he
said quote enjoy today censorship
crackdown in retaliation is coming
social media exposed the fake news media
that can't be allowed to happen again
that's the words of mike cernovich and i
think he brings up a very interesting
point because if you are the people
pulling the strings if you are the
corporate media you just have egg on
your face today you lost a very big
public case that you were purporting as
something totally different from the
reality of it and the thing that broke
the reality of it is independent people
saying enough is enough here's the truth
here's the evidence here's the pictures
here's the documents judge for yourself
there's a big difference between the two
this is going to send
wavelengths especially to the people in
charge so this is going to be uh
interesting to see how it proceeds and i
agree with mike that it's going to
probably lead with more censorship that
we already have to deal with because
already the the the game is so rigged
against us no matter what happens in the
media the mainstream media the corporate
media always get favor favor they always
get notifications sent out to their
viewers they always get on the front
page we don't and we're still competing
with them now that that should send
alarm bells to these people in charge
more than anything else you can't uh you
can't change the direction of the wind
you can't adjust it you feel like we are
on a general trajectory towards winning
then because i'm trying to keep this
optimistic yes the mood going um but
kind of on to what you said it's like up
until very very recently maybe even just
a few weeks ago you couldn't even tweet
or facebook post a word of support for
carl renton house because you'd be
banned you still can't in a lot in a lot
of these platforms i'm pretty sure you
can't on facebook you can't on instagram
because my friend just got banned for
reposting my tweet i think you can on
twitter instagram twitter
yeah i don't know interestingly there's
a cassandra fairbanks had a old tweet
where she said that kyle right now did
nothing wrong yeah i saw that and then
she got she got forced to delete it and
she tweeted again like i'd like to have
a word with you i just tweeted cal
rittenhouse did nothing wrong
says a jury of his peers yes i added
something small i did the same thing no
lie it's found well i'm just reporting
the news yeah exactly does it jury but
it's an objective fact i mean to be fair
they didn't say he did nothing wrong
yeah they said he was not guilty of the
crimes for which he was charged
reasonable doubt right that's it that
was the standard to be met i don't
understand anybody who's watched that
trial and didn't arrive at
reasonable doubt that went through my
head a lot last week
let's take a look at their perspective
coming moving forward from the guardian
kyle rittenhouse has walked free now
it's open season on protesters
this is this is this is the narrative
that they that they're they're going
with the cal right now as president
arguing that um now
right-wing militias are going to go out
and do copycat and all stuff and i'm
like dude
so you're saying that right-wing
individuals will go out get attacked by
rioters and then defend themselves and
it's a copycat because that's what you
that's what would have to happen to be a
copycat i hate those conflation of
protesters and rioters yeah it makes me
so sick
because
again going back to having lived in a
city where this happened there was a
very clear divide it's like so once
night what's it was like around like
golden hour like maybe five six pm it
would be
blm protesters some of them were angry
but there wasn't a ton of violence the
night would go on progressively things
got sketchier and sketchier a few fires
popped up and it was antifa coming in
and doing that um so if you lived in
these things when it happened you know
which ones are protesters which ones are
rioters and what was happening in
kenosha was a riot yep a quite bad one
we i'll just i'll just see just show
this article real quick
and you can keep talking i want to make
sure people on the screen um and and i
we were down there on some night where
there was like a protest turned into a
riot and you could see them all like
standing around like zombies before like
the door gets open and they all charge
out of the door weird dude mob mentality
scares me
so much
so much weird isn't it
you know so i have to tell the story
about when i was in venezuela covering
the the riots down there
and there's this street so imagine the
street and we're you know so we're so
here's the street i'm standing here the
national guard of venezuela's here the
protesters are here we we filmed a
little bit then we walked over and i
turned left
at some point the crowd that was here
north ran full speed all screaming in
the same direction so i ran
west
and i thought to myself after that
why is it that the people who were in
the group were scared of something to
their south where the national guard was
so they all ran the same way it's as if
a boulder had fallen down like an
indiana jones and instead of taking two
steps sideways they just run in the
direction the boulder is going it's like
that's the danger of mob mentality they
all scream so everyone runs with each
other
in the same direction for which they're
all being targeted i'll be honest indie
could have run under the boulder
run towards i've watched that movie 30
times since i was a kid he could have
made it underneath the boulder let it go
and then just no it didn't actually
stalk it out no there's a little bit of
space underneath if you're watching and
this is something you're very passionate
about yeah yeah i still want him but
remember remember have you seen
prometheus yes this the ship is rolling
and she's just running in the direction
it's like run sorry take two steps to
your right what are you doing panic is
the worst enemy you don't want to be
part of that you don't want to be part
of friends
yeah definitely
frenzy is a good word for what went down
in kenosha a better word than my
mentality thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you